[Music]
all right ladies 80 of us
are wearing the wrong size bra and guess
what it's not our fault because when was
the last time you actually took the time
to go in for a professional bra fitting
we know it wasn't this past year was it
even the last decade
jeanette goldstein is the ceo of
jeannette bra she was an 80s actress you
might recognize her from aliens
she went to england and discovered
european bras and wanted to bring that
experience and quality back to the
states
now she's got several brick and mortar
stores in la and when the pandemic hit
she began
offering remote profitings you want to
create a really safe space for a woman
to come in because this is
intimate clothing and it's an intimate
experience and you want to be with
someone who's not going to judge you
you're going to have a good time she's
going to meet your needs for both your
life
and your silhouette so in this way we've
just
recreated the in-store experience for
the virtual customer
all right she also says that her pro
sizes go all the way up to a
k-cup she says a good bra is like a good
pair of shoes and a nice pair of glasses
it's certainly an investment and ladies
you are worth it
she says after you get fitted she
promises you're gonna feel like a
million bucks